deuxième objet du courroux de jean paul
belmondo la politique de distribution du
cinéma en france l'auteur pourfend la
mainmise américaine sur les salles
françaises alors que son tout dernier
film désir est tiré de la pièce de sacha
guitry ne sort mercredi prochain que
dans 20 salles au total dont 6 seulement
à paris la colère de belmondo est elle
justifiée réponse avec cette enquête de
son parti merlin lesjak a pris elle a
demandé le programme du mercredi 10
avril dracula film américain a décroché
deux cent soixante trois salles à 10,20
à new york une coproduction franco belge
et allemande 106 à wallace et gromit un
dessin animé anglais 70 salles dès la
sortie est depuis deux semaines dès le
premier jour le dernier disney toy story
s'est installé dans 500 salles désirez
lui n'est attendu que dans 20 salles
donc si seulement à paris
à oui la barbelais oui c'est bizarre
pendentif pas normal
elles vont d'autres mandats d'or
désirait tant aimés de ces dames ne
semble pas l'être des circuits
d'exploitation pourquoi la promotion du
film et elle reléguée à quelques abris
bus man sous sol sur les murs du métro
pourquoi n'y at il aucune affiche sur
les façades des salles qui à ce jour
annonce bien des films je peux pas vous
affirmer que c'est volontaire mais ça
fonctionne normalement comme ça
les boîtes de distribution on passe des
accords avec les grosses boîtes j'essaie
gaumont pathé
c'est là leur fille en général quand
même une bonne répartition des copiés
ils ont vous en faites pas dû pousser
très fort pour que ça se donne
dans cette affaire tout le monde se
renvoie la balle le producteur du film
estime qu'il est victime d'un système le
distributeur dit que ce sont les
exploitants des simples qui n'ont pas
voulu du film l'exploitant en
l'occurrence monsieur seydoux de la
gomme au précise qu'il n'a pas donné
plus de salles parce que désiré n'est
qu'un téléfilm mais parions que belmondo
saura remonter les bretelles à tout ce
petit monde
précisément avant d'entendre dans un
instant la réaction du ministre concerné
fille douce de blaye quitte avec nous en
direct de tarbes tout de suite la parole
à l'accusation jean paul belmondo qui
mais vous allez l'entendre sévèrement en
cause la politique des grands
distributeurs français propos recueillis
par pascale deschamps il ya six salles à
paris ii en banlieue donc c'est un film
qui au départ est totalement assassinés
alors que c'est un très bon film et
c'est un film j'insiste puisque malgré
ce que dit monsieur seydoux de la
gaumont c'est pas un film de télé c'est
un film vrai film si pour lui il faut
que les explosions des cars qui
explosent pour que ce soit un film non
ça c'est un vrai film avec un texte de
sacha guitry guitry appartient au
patrimoine français et des dialogues
extraordinaire il ya une distribution
hors pair il ya jean yanne fanny ardant
béatrice dalle claude rich qu'est ce qui
leur faut de plus et c'est un très bon
film alors là je m'incline mais vous
savez je suis comme tout bon dieu
manquer les films bon s'il ne marche pas
vous n'avez jamais entendu crier jamais
rien dit j'accepte le verdict du public
mais si vous ne donnez pas la chance un
film d'entrés vous le massacre est vous
le sortez comme ça en vitesse dans six
salles là je vous prie gueule voilà est
par contre si sur le cinéma américain
qu'est ce qu'on fait quand vous sauve
casino reid saivet bon c'est une chose
mais pour avoir ça ces exploitants
qu'est-ce qu'il faut qu'ils se prennent
15 nanar américain derrière un alors
nous en sort d'aider des nanars et des
nanars américain moi j'attaque pas le
cinéma américain j'aime beaucoup de
cinéma américain mais cinéma américain
et comme tous les cinémas il a aussi des
très mauvais film alors ne nous les
renvois et regardez ce qu'ils prennent
eux les américains comme film français
et prennent que dalle ou prêts nous
sommes dans des petites salles et patati
et nous ces gens là sont à genoux devant
leurs fonds laporte travaille avec eux
pour avoir un spielberg dans les prêts à
n'importe quoi à prendre 10 15 km à
l'heure après total il ya plus de salles
pour le pour certains films français
donc vous êtes avec désiré comme
quelqu'un le disais dans la presse ce
matin victime d'un système tout à fait
je pensais être victimes si ça mais je
pense que j'ai droit d'ouvrir ma gueule
parce que ça fait 40 ans que j'en vends
j'ai je pense rapporter beaucoup de sous
au cinéma français il rapportait
beaucoup de sous à ses exploitants j'en
ai gagné aussi beaucoup je sais le
reconnaître et je trouve que le cinéma
français a besoin de vivre a besoin
aussi de vedettes ici quand les vedettes
sortent des films vous les assassiner
d'entrer un jour n'aurait plus de dette
américaine et ces gens là sont bien
embêtés les premiers vous en avait
appelé au ministre de la culture qu'est
ce que vous attendez de lui qu'est ce
qu'il peut faire à l'intérieur de ce
système juste mais je crois que ma
culture et bien ce n'est pas parce que
ils dépensent suis vieux mais je crois
qu'il est à l'écouté de tous il sait le
danger dans lequel se trouve le cinéma
français j'attends de lui qu'il fasse
comprendre qui est une sorte de quota
que les film français ne soient
pas pénalisés par rapport au cinéma
américain et c'est pas de répondre les
gens vont pas voir les cinémas des films
français c'est que quand vous rentrez
dans ce raisonnement alors s'en sort
plus parce que c'est fini il ya qu'a dit
on sort plus de films français il valoir
que d'américains s'étend sur les
banlieues on vous parle toujours de la
banlieue les banlieues la violence un
truc qui existe c'est vrai et qu'est ce
qu'on fait en banlieue dans les
complexes de banlieue ont leur fougue
des trucs où il ya les têtes qui éclate
et les cerveaux qui ce pack au plafond
on tue du flic que ça croyez que ces
gens sont aussi belle pour pas les voir
désirer mais ça leur plairait pourquoi
ça ne plairait pas ils ont pas envie de
voir que de la violence ils ont la
violence chez eux sans arrêt elle est là
présent si on leur donne un autre coup
ça rêve ça un petit peu je crois que
c'est une bonne chose de leur montrer
faut pas les prendre plus haut pour plus
bêtes qu'ils sont alors on dit